the risk factor is too high of like not
being funny when you're [ __ ] with a
crowd at least in my head it is but it
actually now that with the proliferation
of
uh crowd work videos on Instagram I
realize these [ __ ] laugh at any
anything you do in the crowd will get
people to laugh the bar is so low
because audiences know that when you're
doing your act like this is a polished
thing like present something to us that
is like the bar is high you've worked on
this most audiences know that you're not
riffing up there but when you go in the
crowd there's no way unless you planted
someone that you have that you figured
out what to do and so people are just so
amazed by any kind of wit that goes on
there so you just get look at this guy
certain people are like oh my God like
and it's of the moment so and I love
crowd work too I used to love it when I
would go see stand up so um I'm
challenging myself to do it more but it
doesn't happen how do you get into it
um I just it really depends sometimes I
just I'll like kill the energy a little
bit on purpose just so I can like talk
to somebody but that seems insane to me
so you'll you'll have momentum and
you'll go I'm gonna choose
who enjoyed discomfort a little bit Yeah
I do and it probably creates a place for
you where you're like that's where you
get motivated are you like a last minute
type person like you get your [ __ ] done
under the yeah yeah I definitely like
the pressure yeah I like when it's
awkward that's that'll bring it putting
just talking to someone can you just
tell because you you've done crowd work
probably more than me even though I've
been doing stand up like 18 times as
long as you like I've been doing it 20
years but I don't go in the crowd at all
so I'm asking like do you
do you just like look at a guy that like
might want it because who do you because
some people do not want it at all I
don't know I have a weird funnier yeah
but you know what these people pay money
to see you and then you're gonna make
them feel weird like I feel bad well
they're they're so there's two funny
ones one one guy was like a [ __ ] this
was like the most awkward one he was
like a cop or some [ __ ] I made a joke
about police and then I looked at him
I'm like you're a cop man and he didn't
he didn't say [ __ ] he just stared back
at me and and I was like cool
and the whole room was like the room was
like like moving and I was like what's
your name
nothing I was like all right I was like
you can shoot me later what's up okay
yeah that's great yeah but I just like
kept hammering it so I definitely
there's definitely people who just don't
respond yeah yeah did you see the clip
of
um what's the what Akash right yeah yeah
yeah yeah oh yeah he's funny his uh clip
of the British guy yeah the guy in the
front row that was doing that same sort
of thing yeah like probably like
probably like one of the worst people to
do crowd work with and this guy was just
like yeah just totally different on his
phone rolling his eyes oh I remember
this is kind of a hipstery looking guy
yeah is that right he was so good I
hated that guy sorry I I need to [ __ ]
I just now that you brought the
wheelchair in the cerebral palsy thing I
have yeah
this dude's been opening for me a guy
named Tyler Walsh super interesting guy
used to be a rodeo clown and then got in
a stand-up yeah love this guy to death
um he's I took him to San Jose was the
first time he saw the ocean so he's like
from rural Nebraska there's certain
things he has I don't even meet this guy
um the Omaha Funny Bone oh nice yeah
yeah yeah
um so yeah I love Colleen Colleen yeah
yeah yeah yeah she's great yeah you know
totally yeah she's a sweetie she is a
big sweetie yeah so she's the best no
but uh so he came with me to Salt Lake
City and there was a girl in the front
row he starts doing a set and then she
just goes [ __ ] and then he goes the
[ __ ] you say to me and he kind of gets a
little aggressive and then she kind of
says a little bit more and he can't
quite figure out what's going on
and then
her friend next to her goes she has
Tourette's and he's like oh
oh no so he like kind of shuts down he
like brings it back he comes back into
the Green Room he's like I'm so sorry
man
um I hope I didn't ruin the show I I
never I'm from rural Nebraska I met a
liberal for the first time this year I
never met someone with Tourette's I was
like as if Tourette's is like yeah yeah
I was like Tyler go out on this second
show and say that [ __ ] that's the
funniest [ __ ] thing you said all day
yeah so yeah Tourette's is one that'll
get I was like at a place where you just
go up to the front and order your bowl
or whatever and this I was like I'll
take you know the keto bowl with and
she's like [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
and I was just like oh my God but it
seemed like it was like she was mad okay
and she goes I have Tourette's and I was
like I am the best person for you to
have Tourette like I was like that's
this is awesome I was like I don't care
at all but this poor girl must deal with
that all day long like and yeah it sucks
like I feel like um I like when the
crowd gets like really weird about
something and then I stay chill about I
feel like that's where I thrive It's
when um I just feel bad I guess when
it's someone who has like social anxiety
or like stage fright yeah yeah I I could
actually say disclaimer at the top of my
shows of like you know if your boyfriend
brought you here and you're in the first
rows and you're gonna spend the whole
show being like oh she doesn't talk to
me oh she doesn't talk to me like like a
lot of times I do meet and greets
afterwards and they're like I didn't go
to the bathroom the whole time because I
just didn't want you to see me I'm like
so the whole show you're holding your
pee and like miserable you can't focus
like so I say disclaimer of like I'm not
gonna talk to you like unless someone
heckles me I'm not gonna make fun of you
you can get up to go to the bathroom I'm
not gonna be like look at this lady
going to take a [ __ ] and like have the
spotlight find it yeah yeah this is why
people are terrified yeah yeah yeah when
we see people get up in ourselves like
are you gonna take a poop yeah
dude this girl this girl waiting oh
girls hate it yeah yeah I know this girl
waited at the one of the Columbus shows
like to like I hit a clock I was like an
hour 20 and she's like I gotta go so she
gets him she goes I'm like oh you gotta
yeah yeah she's farting already yeah
yeah dude that's being a 12 year old she
was like what I'm like careful it's
gonna fall out you've probably caused
kidney infections after that happened of
people coming here like seriously people
are so scared because I just want to
make people feel this is the I think key
to stand up between their legs yeah I
always go go if you have to go go in
your seat this isn't about you this is
me yeah
um but I just want to make people feel
comfortable because I think that's you
know if you're looking at it from like a
broader sense of like what we do as
comedians most people like Seinfeld has
a joke about most people are like their
biggest fear is public speaking they'd
rather be
um they'd rather be in the casket than
giving the eulogy like you more than
death and so most people coming to see
you are going like oh my God I could
never [ __ ] do that you have to talk a
whole hour and you don't look at your
notes and you have to remember how do
you I mean their mind is racing of how
you can do that how you can remember all
that are you gonna remember all that if
I was that I couldn't and they're just a
tense for you you know when you like
watch them so the best comedians are the
ones that just look look like I've got
this yeah don't worry and it's so hard
to fake that so you usually can't you
just gotta be comfortable but I think
the if you hold a gun to the audience
it's way easier
yeah
it's uh my my nephew got a gun
oh man he's not from Colorado okay all
right all right I have a real problem
out there yeah
it's it's always Colorado I mean it's
over easy first of all I love this
because I'm always the one just pushing
it a little too much in my life no I'm
really glad that you brought up school
shootings because I'm I'm like I haven't
because I have an announcement so coming
up Denver no um oh my God no I
last time I shot my special there and
this time I'm gonna shoot
someone special
and icky has a real affinity for special
people
I'm this is over it's over yeah we're
done dude oh man we are on tour uh you
can come see us we won't have careers
Cody will still be here we're hoping for
Kyle Rittenhouse
or opening the door that he comes
through all right all right all right
all right no but I'm like I'm weird
anyway I'm weirdly obsessed with like
columbine I've read like four books
about it this year why are people
obsessed with that like yes it's a thing
on Tick Tock like girls are like think
that the guys are like the sexiest oh
God yeah it's really [ __ ] weird male
gays on women y'all like dudes that it
shoots though no that is a thing like
they're all like they have like armor
and stuff tandem yeah people make like
edits of them I have seen I've I've
heard of that before that's not my uh I
have no like I'm not like yeah they're
so hot I'm just like I guess it happened
my freshman year of high school and so
it was just like this I mean it was why
there were school shootings before that
but I don't know that one Remains the
one that everyone knows about it was
just so yeah I'm just into things that
are really morbid I'm not as into like
cereal for some reason serial killers
women being into that is like completely
acceptable you know like oh my God
Dahmer's gonna like win Emmys and stuff
and everyone kind of accepts it but I'm
into school shooting like the mind of
Shooters I'm like very and pedophiles
and people are like what's wrong with
you I'm like I don't know it's just like
it's it is the craziest thing to me
Beyond serial killing I guess and so I'm
fascinated by it but my nephew did get a
gun um not a real gun but like a toy gun
my mom bought him one for um from like
she like shops at Goodwill and she got
this toy that was like a dinosaur and
you should but he just took the gun he
was like shooting us like Point Blank
yeah and we had to do a buyback program
sorry
I promise that wasn't a setup for that
joke
turn it in damn but uh but I wonder like
did you guys stop taking my gun
yeah he like he quoted the Second
Amendment I was like you're four
um wait did you guys have toy guns
growing like you're a bit younger than
me when did it happen where everyone was
like no more like it was when BB guns
and [ __ ] is that what you mean like like
toy like you're dead like I feel like
people don't water guns yeah I mean but
I grew up in the next oh like real guns
no guns were way more realistic yeah I
remember I think I was I think I was
like
I want to say like 10 and there was that
there was like that big National story
of the kid pulling out the airsoft gun
and the cops shooting them yeah and then
or maybe maybe I was more like 12 or 14
but it was like early teens and then
that's when all the guns kind of
switched over yes yes but I was like
they were we were just freaking out like
he can't have this and he keeps and my
dad's like when I was a young boy I had
toy guns but I didn't suit them at
people and I'm like of course you did
yeah but now we're looking at that like
that's so bad like he's gonna be a
shooter someday it's like no what are
you supposed to the wall yeah they're
gonna shoot their Aunt Nikki yeah
[ __ ] head he would come out to me and
be like put it against my temple and I'm
just like okay
Jesus yeah so FYI Island